Anatole even is senior associate at the
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace an expert in u.s. foreign policy
and is author of this book America right
or wrong and anatomy of American
nationalism mr. Levin what do you think
of US foreign policy right now not a
great deal to be honest I mean I very
strongly supported the war on terror
when it began the campaign in
Afghanistan where I used to work as a
journalist many years ago but of course
like so many Americans I felt that the
the decision to go to war in Iraq was a
very grave error and that has actually
weakened the war on terror in fact you
write that this country the US had a
chance to create a concert of all the
world's major states including Muslim
ones against Islamic Revolutionary
terrorism it chose instead to pursue
policies which divided the West further
alienated the Muslim world and exposed
America itself to greatly increase
danger tell us more
well I think the war in Iraq has done
all these things but that is I believe a
consensus within much of the CIA and a
large part of the foreign policy
community when it comes to the Muslim
world because of course the war in Iraq
was bitterly opposed by most Muslims if
you follow the opinion polls whereas the
war against al-qaeda enjoys the sympathy
of far more Muslims of course there are
supporters of al Qaeda but because al
Qaeda represents this totalitarian
revolutionary form of Islam it's
possible to put together a coalition of
Muslim forces against it
whereas what America now appears to
Muslims to be doing in terms of really
dominating the Middle East as a whole is
really quite unacceptable to a majority
of Muslim opinion tell us about this
notion of American nationalism what does
that all mean well it's usually called
patriotism here of course but until a
few decades ago it was quite common in
America to speak of nationalism after
all in most of the world one talks of
nationalism which isn't necessarily you
know an ethno-religious nationalism in a
narrow sense you can have a civic
nationalism based on values and this is
what
the mainstream of American nationalism
is you become an American by adopting
American values but it is still
nonetheless a very strong nationalism a
very strong belief very often in the
superiority of America the uniqueness of
the American system and America's right
to go out and spread that system to the
rest of the world our guest has a
bachelor's and PhD from Cambridge
University speaks Russian French and
German he is Anatole leavin and will be
with us for 40 minutes here are the
numbers to call if you want to ask a
question of our guest or make a comment
if you support President Bush call two
oh two six two eight zero two zero five
if you support Democrats the number for
you is 202 737 triple zero two and if
you support others two oh two six two
eight zero one eight four we look
forward to your thoughts mr. Levin and
talk to us about the major factors that
have changed u.s. foreign policy since
9/11 well obviously it was 9/11 but what
I argue in the book is that 9/11 didn't
really create anything very new in
America what it did was to strengthen or
empower trends in American political
culture which were actually a very
long-standing and I trace these
traditions in American political culture
and foreign policy back into American
history on the basis I must say of a
great American historiographical and
critical tradition as represented by
people like richard hofstadter lewis
hearts senator Fulbright and others you
write about Andrew Jackson as well
Jacksonian nationalism you spent some
time on it take us deeper into that well
I talk of the American nationalist
thesis being a civic nationalism based
on values the values of democracy
individualism the rule of law and this
is the thesis that Americans put forward
about America to themselves and to the
world and that is a Universalist thesis
and it's an optimistic one but there is
also this darker strain in America which
I see as originating very much in the
history of racial tension and conflict
on this continent which really far from
seeing and
can values as universal sees them very
much as confined to America that this is
an American civilization that it can't
necessarily be exported that far from
you know being apprehended by foreigners
foreigners are actually inherently
hostile to America and therefore rather
than an open outgoing society America
should be a closed defensive one and I
think after 9/11 we've obviously seen a
great strengthening of this kind of
attitude as well before we go to calls
tell us how American nationalism is
perceived throughout the world and and
and explain why the US should be
concerned about this well of course if
you look at the opinion polls really in
almost all parts of the world it's
perceived very badly and this is a track
a tragedy because after 9/11 there
really was this great wave of sympathy
and support for America particularly in
my own country of Britain because you
can argue sure that in some countries
like France even Western countries there
is this deep strain of anti-americanism
and that for a lot of French people
perhaps it really doesn't matter what
America does but that certainly isn't
true in Britain it was overwhelming
support for America after 9/11 not now
we see that support very very qualified
we see Tony Blair in very serious
trouble and well one reason why America
should be concerned about this is that
if American actions in the Middle East
helped to bring down Tony Blair then
America loses really probably its most
valuable ally in the whole world and
certainly its most important ally in
Europe and that is a very bad blow to
American security and American foreign
policy interests our guest has authored
several books has worked as
correspondent for the Financial Times in
Eastern Europe based in Budapest he's
covered Pakistan Afghanistan India
Romania other countries Anatole Lieven
takes the first call now from Los
Angeles hello hello mr. Libin I disagree
with your contention that the war in
Iraq is wrong I'm a little out of breath
because I just ran to the phone but jobs
excuse me sir America was founded by the
founding fathers with
prophecy rooted in the heavens that
America would ultimately change to the
world for the better
and President Bush has been forced by no
choice of his own to make the
distinction to the world that he is
going to fulfill that prophecy and sir
with your regards to racial tension in
the United States you're right there's a
civil war in 2004 in the United States
and I'll close my comments by this CNN
MSNBC and Fox News are broadcasting live
from the graveyard in America they are
the equivalent of an American al Qaeda
and the American people should wise up
and realize that there is discontent
among Americans and it's not a process
of foreign observers that come to
America and and make their judgments and
cast their call thanks caller for your
points mr. Libin take that first point
that the caller mentioned prophecy what
do you make of folks who feel that way
think that way well I write about this a
great deal in the bush or this idea of
American messianism now I should say but
in the book I emphasize very strongly
that I believe in the force of America's
example in that I also follow a great
American tradition going all the way
back to President Adams and represented
once again by William Fulbright would
you say that America spreads its model
best when it shows its example not when
it goes out to try to conquer other
countries and spread its its message by
those means but I must also say you know
in response to what the caller said
about foreigners coming here once again
Britain is America's closest ally we
have 11,000 troops on the ground in Iraq
if a British citizen you know doesn't
have a right to make comments you know
on America and American policy as well
who does no other high gentleman first
of all I love the accent I totally agree
with you we had no right to take a
detour we were looking for bin Laden and
go into Iraq this is a bloodbath that I
don't believe will ever be saw
I'm on the very very believer in God but
I'm not a fanatic with it but when I
think of all of the bloodshed and our
soldiers that are dying over there just
because Bush wants his agenda to go
through it makes me absolutely sick and
I will buy your book I love what you say
and you say it very well thank you for
seeing appreciate you calling thanks
Jill even how long can the Iraq war go
on do you think well it can go on
forever indeed I believe that in a
certain sense it will go on and
virtually indefinitely because whatever
system America succeeds in putting in
place in Iraq if it succeeds and even if
America succeeds in withdrawing from
Iraq it's absolutely clear that there
will be very powerful forces that will
go on fighting and there are very few
examples in history of a country being
able you know really to suppress foot
forces as powerful as this representing
such a large section of the population
particularly of course in an era of
terrorism because in the past you could
if you were ruthless enough and you had
enough force suppress a rebellion or a
guerrilla war but as the Russians are
finding in Chechnya
the Russians have won the war on the
ground in Chechnya the the guerrilla war
is way down but the terrorist war
continues terrorism gives the enemy so
many more opportunities to strike back
so in a certain sense I don't think
we're ever going to see an end to this
war all that being said injector
diplomacy into all this hair what would
you suggest that the Condoleezza Rice do
as she becomes Secretary of State well
what I would advise her to do I'm sure
she won't do it is to imitate Nixon and
Kissinger which is to say to make a
hard-headed realpolitik decision to
reach out to certain Muslim countries
who have hitherto been seen as our
enemies just as China was seen as our
enemies but which in fact are hostile to
the forces against which we are really
fighting now and that means first and
foremost Iran because the Iranian Shia
conservative regime has historically
been of course bitterly hostile both to
the Sunni
greenest forces represented by al Qaeda
and its allies but also obviously to
Bath style Arab nationalism or fascism
against which of course they fought an
appalling ly bloody war in the 1980s so
I think there are many grands there for
going to Tehran the way that um Nixon
went to Beijing 30 years ago and I think
that you know all this talk of going to
Europe and get and gaining an
international consensus there to support
Iraq is largely empty its Muslim
countries you need to back the
stabilization of Iraq let's go to
Berkeley Springs Indiana welcome to the
program hi there that's Berkeley Springs
West Virginia West Virginia should have
known that hi yeah sir as as a person
whose father shed blood to prevent
Hitler from swallowing you guys up and
one who has been called to active duty
in 62 to keep the communism from
swallowing up the whole of Europe I
don't give a damn what you think about
our president or our foreign policy
thank you
well caller all that being said why
would you watch this segment then want
to know what his interest was if he
totally disagrees with you why why go on
to listen but he's gone but but go ahead
and respond well just what I said before
I mean after we are fighting in Iraq
Britain is fighting in Iraq Britain has
supported America throughout the war on
terror I have to say as well sorry but
we fought Hitler for two years and three
months before America came into the war
and my father was an officer my mother
was an ambulance driver Brittany doesn't
have to apologize to anybody for its
record in fighting Hitler Ann Arbor
Michigan good morning good morning
c-span three quick points first I think
our country's been hijacked by
fundamentalist just like Islam has been
hijacked by fundamentalist supposedly
secondly wouldn't have been easier to
bring freedom and democracy to our
friends in Saudi Arabia Pakistan Jordan
Egypt and all the other Emirates
thirdly I believe that sending a
Christian army into the Muslim world
with no Muslim allies is a single
stupidest thing and the American
president has ever done
mr. Lieven take that first point about
fundamentalist says he calls them yes I
mean I wouldn't say myself that they are
anything like as bad as you know
fundamentalist sin in the Muslim world
but I do talk about this a great deal in
in my book and it's not that you know I
am in any sense hostile to religion even
conservative religion I was after all
raised in a conservative Catholic
household myself but I do find that the
very embittered and radical and
aggrieved edge of some conservative
religion in America both at home and
abroad
is becoming increasingly dangerous it's
dividing America or helping to divide
America but it is also contributing in
my view to some very irrational foreign
policy attitudes and courses when it
comes to the war in Iraq I would argue
very that whenever possible in the war
on terror which by the way to repeat I
strongly support but whenever possible
America must act through local allies it
must find Muslims who are willing to
fight against the terrorists against Al
Qaeda now in Iraq against the bath
because yes I mean sometimes we have to
use our own troops and I myself believe
it would have been better if we'd used
far more American and British troops in
Afghanistan for example but that I
believe should be the exception we
should only do that when we absolutely
have to broaden that mr. Libin to talk
about the UN and the role the UN should
have if any in Iraq the UN is a very
ambiguous institution from this point of
view because after all it does represent
States and most of the states in the
world are very unhappy with the war in
Iraq they don't want to encourage
America that unit to go in for more
adventures of this kind on the other
hand of course they also don't want
erupted to collapse into chaos but the
result is that there is a great lack of
will in the UN
now when it comes to helping America in
Iraq that's you know when it comes to
the membership of the UN among states
when it comes to the UN as an
organization of course well it there's a
tremendous air of bewilderment I think
now in New York because on the one hand
the administration has said repeatedly
that it wants more UN support in Iraq
that it wants more UN help with various
issues around the world but of course
parts of this administration have also
been sponsoring this very savage
campaign against the UN as an
institution because of the corruption in
the Saddam Hussein's oil-for-food
program well now even if a lot of these
charges are justified well one could say
hey what is this administration to you
know to accuse other people of
corruption but also it's just bad
diplomacy once again you don't do that
to an organization if on the other hand
you really wanted support Tuscaloosa
Alabama good morning to you hi yeah
thank you I'm a bush supporter but I
just want to say the the most
frustrating part of the whole war is I
believe that instead of combating
terrorism the president and his and his
staff has made a playing fields for
terrorism whereas example the USS Cole
when that was bomb our US Justice
Department sought out and tried to
prosecute the perpetrators at hand now
there in Iraq any Muslim and Islamic
extremists have a field day in Iraq
where they can go and kill you this
troop anonymously caller just want to
make sure I heard right did you say
you're a former Bush supporter okay okay
but what I'm saying is I'm a bit
frustrated with with the way the task at
hand been handled I see mr. Libin well
there are a great many people in the
uniformed military and in the CIA as
well the intelligence community who
would absolutely
your frustration although the serving
ones of course can't say so openly or on
the record but we know there have been a
succession of senior anti-terrorism
people like Mike Shire who've come out
and said pretty much exactly what what
you've been saying yes I mean I I
believe that we should have concentrated
absolutely like a laser on the group
which carried out 9/11 which murdered
3,000 Americans and of course hundreds
of Britons and other foreigners and
really gone after them and their allies
and it seems to me in that context that
we have forgotten one of the critical
lessons of the Cold War or you could say
just one of the critical lessons of war
in general which is that you must try to
avoid uniting enemies against you you
must do everything possible to split and
divide your enemies and to weaken them
from within and initially we fail to do
that in the Cold War and that was one
reason why America got involved in
Vietnam after that lesson once again to
repeat Nixon and Kissinger learned that
they could split China from the Soviet
Union that they could split China from
Vietnam that they could essentially use
one communist state and one communist
movement against others that I believe
is what we ought to be doing in the
Muslim world and that is something that
the Iraq war has made a good deal more
difficult you mentioned the Cold War mr.
Levin you have written quite a bit about
Russia and Ukraine as we know and the
opposition leader whose chanko is
claiming victory now in Ukraine is we've
heard over the weekend talk to us about
this particular situation Ukraine as it
relates to Russia u.s. relations and
then you can broaden the topic overall
as it relates to the entire world go
ahead well what's happened in in Ukraine
is a tremendously good thing and you
know you you have had for the first time
in that country and really one of the
first times in the former Soviet Union
outside the the Baltic States in masses
of people really coming out and
demonstrating agitating for democracy
for greater freedom for honesty and
transparency in government so that's a
very good thing but of course on the
other hand
that the latest exit polls tend to
suggest about 55% for whatever you want
to call him the Liberal Democratic
challenger mr. Yushchenko but 40% of
Ukrainians in this time of free vote you
know what seems to have been free free
and fair election 40 percent have still
voted for the prime minister Yanukovych
and have also voted to maintain a very
close relationship with Russia and the
reasons are often that Americans and
Westerners should understand their jobs
depend on Russia they speak Russian
their intermarried with Russians very
many of them are working in Russia so
this is a very important segment of the
Ukrainian population a Democratic
segment and its interests also must be
taken into account so I think you know
the way we need to organize our policy
in the West and I'd say this the EU as
well as the the United States is that we
must support Ukrainian democracy
Ukrainian Progress Ukrainian reform but
we mustn't allow this to be turned into
a revival of the Cold War in other words
for Ukraine not against Russia unless of
course the Russian government makes some
makes any other policy impossible so can
that happen can Ukraine have a close
relationship with both Russia and the US
yes I think so I mean it depends on how
we set about it but after all you know
Russia is also very weak state in some
ways by now
this isn't Czechoslovakia in 1968 or
Hungary in 1956
you know Russian tanks are not going to
roll into Ukraine but any Ukrainian
government is going to have to balance
to some extent and I think that we
should actually encourage that and then
if we can you know keep moderately good
relations with Russia while encouraging
Ukrainian reform then hopefully you know
over the next decade or so Ukraine will
develop towards the west it will become
more Western it will become more
democratic and then hopefully it will
naturally
join the West in the long run moving on
to Beverly New York for Anatole leaving
good morning hi good morning good
morning mr. Levin I'm a first-time
caller um I have a comment and then I
also have a question for mr. Levin I'm a
military mom and my son served with the
Army in a in Iraq I really don't think
we had any business going in Iraq as
horrible as 9/11 was to all of us in the
United States we were not attacked by
Iraq we had a right to go to Afghanistan
we needed to stay there and complete the
job at hand that's where we need it to
be and I know that we are in Iraq I just
don't know how we're going to get out of
that mess that we got ourselves into and
my heart just bleeds every day for
what's going on there and you know being
a military mom I see what's going on
there and even though it's not my kid
that's getting blown up every day you
cry every day for the person who lost
their children and it's just horrible
my question is know that mr. Blair has
lost mr. blanket who is moving over to
take over at you know take over for him
I miss mr. blanket why did you guys jump
this massive you know from the farm
industry you know what will will mr.
Blair do without his support he was such
an intricate part of that support for
what was going on thanks caller let's
get a response well Blair has certainly
been badly weakened by this but that the
way a Labour MPs said it to me not long
ago was that
Blair's political immune system has been
so weakened by the Iraq war and what
many British people see as you know his
slavish following of Bush that he's now
vulnerable to scandals which two or
three years ago he would essentially
have shrugged off and that you know one
day soon
it may be quite a small scandal that
carries him off and as I say this would
be a very bad thing for American foreign
policy interests as to the US military
ID I would like to say that you know I
am in no sense of pacifist I supported
the first Iraq war I supported the
intervention in the Balkans I supported
the war in Afghanistan as a British
citizen I even supported the war in the
Falklands and I supported the
bombardment of of Libya I have nothing
but the deepest respect and appreciation
for American soldiers and if I could say
so British soldiers as well and I do
believe by the way that one of the bad
things about Iraq is that because of the
way in which we've got bogged down there
because of our inability to control this
insurgency we've actually weakened this
tremendous image of the all-powerful
American military after Afghanistan
which I think had a really valuable
effect in frightening potential enemies
now unfortunately are not as frightened
as they should be and what I'm afraid of
is that this may make more Wars
in future not less likely as the Bush
administration claims but more like take
a call from a to Oklahoma good morning
good morning my compliments to your book
sir I believe it or not I am aware
supporter but I also think you might
have a question anaconda my comment is
is I don't think President Bush is a
student of history with Great Britain's
own history as you can probably verify
with Royal Britannia in the Boxer Wars
Great Britain didn't understand that the
Chinese didn't want that right or wrong
and also with India Afghanistan and in
Great Britain's history and in European
history they realized that their
insights were not the insights of the
people that they were occupying and I'd
really don't think President Bush's
understand the European lesson I don't
think it's colonialism imperialism I
just think that President Bush right or
wrong has gotten himself into a
situation where he doesn't listen to
anybody who's saying listen look at what
happened in European history when they
tried this look at the Bark's the war
for Great Britain was saying hey this is
art way of life and how come you don't
like it and maybe with another leader as
president maybe Europe could say listen
we tried this before it's not working
this is how we got out of it maybe we
could help you and I really don't think
President Bush is really reading what
the lessons of history has happened
before
Thanks let's get a response from our
guest mr. Levin I think you're
absolutely right I mean it is one
central reason why Europeans and even a
lot of Britons are much less optimistic
about operations like Iraq because of
course we were chased out of a lot of
countries which we had ruled and which
we had tried quote/unquote to civilize
and to develop and the natives as we
used to call them didn't like it and
eventually we either got driven out like
the French and the Dodge or like the
British we pulled out just before we
were going to be driven out but I have
to say I don't think that this is just a
problem of bush or the Bush
administration I know a great many
Democrats in the Democratic foreign
policy elites who also share very much
this idea of America as a messianic
force and that America should make
democratization spreading freedom the
center of its foreign policy now I don't
disagree with that as the underlying
moral meaning of America's place in the
world and as I've said I really believe
in America's example but believing that
you can make this democratization
strategy a substitute for really
studying in other countries for trying
to make compromises with them according
to an understanding of their interests
for respecting their national pride as
America expects its national pride to be
respected democratization is no
substitute for any of these things look
it isn't a substitute for any of these
things in America you know Americans
believe fervently in democracy but
Americans have a very strong and in many
ways very admirable
national pride as well chapter six in
your book you talk quite a bit about US
policy toward Israel I talked to us
about the the israeli-palestinian
conflict to what extent is US policy
toward Israel driving all of us foreign
policy right now I wouldn't say that
it's driving all of us foreign policy
it's only a subsidiary factor but
unfortunately when it comes to relations
with the Muslim world and therefore the
interests of the u.s. in the war on
terror this issue has become pretty
central that that's just not deniable if
you read you know absolutely reputable
respected opinion polls surveys news
reports from American journalists
surveys by the US State Department for
that matter and therefore I mean and in
this I absolutely back on Tony Blair you
may remember he was in Washington
recently emphasized this well he was in
Israel recently and emphasized this that
nothing is more important at the moment
to America's strategy in the war on
terror and America's position in the
Middle East than trying to bring about a
just and stable peace between the
Israelis and the Palestinians at least
perhaps the war in Iraq is even more
important but then again you know the
war in Iraq is going to go on for a very
long time we cannot afford to have this
other permanent crisis going on at the
same time particularly one which does so
stir up Muslim anger against us well how
do you see things playing out I know
that's a tough question to answer based
on everything that's happened the the
the death of Yasser Arafat Sharon's
current policy and statements how do you
see things shaping out in the months
ahead well I think that both sides will
make a really serious effort we've seen
the Palestinian leadership now I mean
making some very strong statements you
know about the need for a purely
peaceful struggle denunciations of
terrorism and so forth and so on
however how long they will really be
able to stick to that or how long they
will be able to control their
radicals like hammers that's very
doubtful
unless Israel can move really pretty
quickly to give the Palestinians
something concrete something very
visible in terms of moves towards real
statehood with a real degree of
independence and with real borders and
you know because we are a lot about the
need for secure borders for Israel but
of course any Palestinian national
movement is going to have to demand
secure borders for for Palestine as well
now I have to say that looking at the
terribly fractured Israeli political
scene and the tremendous power of
extremists you know within Israel as
well as within Palestine I have to say
that I am pretty worried or pretty
skeptical that the the Israeli state
will in fact be able to gain the
necessary degree of of unity to make
such an offer possible I hope that it
will but I'm not holding my breath let's
go to Greenville North Carolina for an
atoll even good morning
yes are misleading and uh the I like to
cover your book America right or wrong
and I will say America is definitely in
the wrong for being over there in Iraq
there's no need to be over there the war
on terror it's totally different than it
has dude I wrecked it and I think mr.
Bush probably you know I feel like he's
kind of self-centered by being over
there and doing what he's doing over
there you know if you're fighting a war
on terror you need to be fighting the
United States as well because there's
terrorists living in the United States
that nothing's being done to them you
know there's just me I'm not gonna say
there's just as many terrorists but
there's terrorists in the United States
we need to be bombing bombing the United
States just bombing Iraq if that's what
you're fighting this term thanks mister
leaving
well I wouldn't suggest doing anything
that radical within the the US but what
I would say is that given what happened
on 9/11 and given that we know there are
these utterly ruthless fanatical
implacable and very clever enemies out
there
there should be much more attention to
Homeland Security in terms for example
of checking on containers the thousands
millions of containers that come into
the US every year and which are not
being checked there should be much more
money going towards control of illegal
immigrants in the US all of these things
are critical to the war on terror but
the problem is now that just isn't the
money for them because it's all you know
disappearing down the endless hole of
Iraq why do you think there has not been
another major attack in this country
well I think that the war in Afghanistan
did knock out Qaeda very badly I mean
don't get me wrong I'm not saying that
everything the Bush administration has
done is bad I think the the initial
campaigning in in Afghanistan although
obviously as we know it had serious
faults and it allowed to summer to get
away nonetheless it did a deprive
al-qaida of its self-hate of its safe
haven of its bases I think we have got
al Qaeda on the run to some extent then
again of course so many of the people
who might otherwise you know be planning
to attack the US are now fighting in
Iraq I mean that's true as far as it
goes but on the other hand we just don't
know what's out there I would be
astonished if the went numerous groups
plotting planning remember how long it
took to plan 9/11 this was no improvised
operation and so I'm afraid that sooner
or later there may well be another
attack of course I pray that that the
wound I'd be either here in America or
in Britain take us back to Europe we
touched on it briefly at the top of the
show I talked to us about US relations
with Europe as these months and years go
forward well look on the one hand Europe
and us are not going to go to war right
I mean at one level but relations are
normal as between major countries in the
world after all the US has a pretty good
relationship with China by now I think
perhaps part of the problem is that you
know during the Cold War because we were
allies against the Soviet Union against
there was this idea that you know we had
to be really really close that in this
idea of the West and that if the West
wasn't solid and working together there
was something terribly wrong with the
world well now I I you know I wish very
much that we could go on cooperating in
this way but if we can't it's not the
end of the world you know we can still
go on dealing pragmatically you know on
many issues and by the way you know when
it comes to sharing intelligence and
police work in the war on terror in the
struggles specifically against Al Qaeda
and its allies
well that's continuing you know not
perfectly because frankly cooperation
between intelligence services is never
perfect cooperation between the FBI and
the CIA isn't perfect but you do have
the French and the Americans working
together you know cooperation of that
kind can continue obviously cooperation
on trade and economics so we can
continue to deal pragmatically even if
we can't agree on everything and real
quick do you think the EU overall views
itself as a counterweight to the US as
some have suggested no not overall the
EU is much too big and much too divided
by now there are some people who think
that in France in Germany but there's no
way that an EU containing Poland and the
Baltic States and Britain by the way
could ever become a counterweight of
that kind so no I I don't think that
that Americans need to worry too much
about that Bradenton Florida thanks for
waiting go ahead please yes good morning
I just like to make a comment the last
two Bush supporters with fakes drives me
nuts but anyway the the gentleman is in
denial he does not understand the danger
of nuclear weapons and that even a a
group like al-qaeda in possession of
these weapons can actually threaten the
sovereignty of our country he assumes
that al-qaeda is the only threat that
completely disregards Islamic
fundamentalism
he naively believes that the war ended
in Afghanistan and he does not give
credence to the fact that the attack on
9/11 was worse than Pearl Harbor and yet
he advocates appeasement and unwittingly
are hopefully unwittingly it gives you
the aid and comfort to our enemy Thank
You mr. Levin
I have never for one single instant
advocated appeasement of al Qaeda or its
allies and I've always used the phrase
al Qaeda and its allies because of
course it's not just al Qaeda there is a
huge net or web of Sunni Islamist
extremists out there and yes I mean as I
said before there are groups who we know
nothing about who may be plotting
against us but I suggest you read the
report of the 9/11 Commission which
found no evidence of serious links
between Al Qaeda and Saddam was saying
and of course US and British
investigators have found no weapons of
mass destruction or even programs
getting close to weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq if it comes to the
threat of States giving weapons of mass
destruction to terrorists well then you
have to ask why Iraq there are other
states including Pakistan which may
represent very much greater dangers in
this regard we cannot invade and occupy
them all we just do not have the troops
in fact America doesn't even have the
troops for one more war after Iraq
that's why I've said that the Iraq war
has weakened us not strengthened us
because our potential enemies don't
believe anymore that we are actually
capable of invading and occupying them
so once again I have been
unconditionally in favor of the most
ruthless struggle against the terrorists
who carried out 9/11 and their allies
Saddam Hussein and Iraq did not carry
out 9/11 and will not link to the people
who did carry out 9/11 and going after
them has been in my view a catastrophic
distraction let's hear from Norwalk
Connecticut for Anatole
Wow thank you Paul please let me have my
say sure go ahead waited so long
Annabeth okay to me
now Bush and all his backers they're
just sitting back in their ivory towers
letting all these innocent lives be lost
just so they can call themselves
patriotic to me is a slap in the face to
our flag and what it stands for these
hypocrites are the first to condemn
anyone burning our flag and yet they
blatantly wear the flag pin in there
lapel everyday as a badge of honor now
I'm speaking of everyone in Congress
we've just letting each day pass with
more lives being lost in all for what an
illegal war now why aren't the ones in
Congress who oppose the war in the first
place
using their clout to get Bush removed
from office as a war criminal
for committing war crimes and treason
before he is sworn in for a second term
now until then I will call Congress a
cya Association that's why as in
yesterday not I as in Iraq nothing more
now there was a book that I've been
trying to push by Justin a Frank called
Bush on the couch which paints the
picture of him as mentally unbalanced he
should be tested very important before
he has sworn him for a second term why
aren't the people listening calling in
getting that book thanks caller UVO
called within the past 30 days but will
let mr. Lieven respond to your point
nonetheless anything you want to grab
there well just that I would never
accuse the Bush administration of
treason I I hate this use of treason
that you know as a means of attacking
enemies at home it's a very serious
charge I think the you know supporter of
the Bush administration have used it
shamefully you know against against some
of their rivals at home these people
believe I'm sure that they are are
patriotic and that said it's also
perfectly obvious that they have used
patriotism or nationalism to garner
domestic political support and to
discredit their enemies and I talk a lot
in the book about the very dangerous and
even sinister ways in which early
in the past have used nationalism in
this way to drive not just a domestic
political agenda but also a domestic
economic agenda I do not believe for
example that anything as radical as the
tax cuts and under this this
administration could have occurred if it
hadn't been for 9/11 and the war on
terror but as far as Congress is
concerned well there is just one point
like it or not the Republicans now
control Congress so of course I mean
you're not going to get the impeachment
of Bush by a Republican Congress what do
you think in Congress overall as it
relates to Iraq in the foreign policy
they're gonna be asked to vote for some
more money soon for Iraq what do you
make of their work over there well
they're certainly gonna have to be asked
for more money and you know the the
present funds are manifestly running out
I mean like so many people I've been
bitterly disappointed by the the role of
Congress you know in voting for the war
in not investigating seriously the
charges that the Bush administration
made as part of its propaganda for going
to war and in not really following up on
scandals like Abu Ghraib and the talk
the torture of detainees and what I say
very strongly in the book is that this
represents a forgetfulness on the part
of the US Congress but also I believe on
the part of the American political
establishment a forgetfulness of the
lessons of Vietnam and one of the
reasons I wrote this book was to remind
Americans of a great American critical
tradition which has written both before
Vietnam in reaction against McCarthyism
but also during Vietnam and this was not
just a left-wing tradition it was also
the tradition of eminently basically
culturally conservative figures like
Reinhold Niebuhr William Fulbright
George Kennan but who detected certain
patterns in America including this
belief in America's right and America's
ability to go out and by force to spread
its system to other countries and that
they wrote these tremendous critiques of
aspects of American political culture
which I was horrified to find in the
debates leading up to Iraq
were never mentioned were never
discussed in the mainstream American
media of course they're well known about
in American academia but they really
have been excluded to a great extent
from the the mainstream political debate
in this country and they still are even
now one is not having a serious
political debate about what it was about
certain American myths that got America
into Vietnam and got America into Iraq
let's get one last call in Cumberland
Maryland good morning good morning I
have my question relates to I look at it
because I'm of the World War two
generation and I see a lot of you know I
kind of wish I could see our troops
fight this war with the same
ruthlessness that we fought World War
two because to me
Islam is a much greater enemy to the
West than the Nazis ever were if
anything I think they're much worse
because they are not of our civilization
but more importantly I look at what's
going on as a Sunni triangle and I would
simply don't understand why we don't
flatten it the same way we did Hamburg
we fire bombed Hamburg we fire bombed
the British fire bombed Leipzig and I
think if they got some of that I think
they really learn to behave things time
for a final thought from our guest well
first of all I'm sorry but I cannot
accept that the Nazi is a part of
anything that I would describe as our
civilization secondly one can well argue
that al-qaeda is a totalitarian and
murderous force akin in some respects to
to to fascism or totalitarianism but it
it is simply a monstrous statement to
say that Islam as a whole that that
hundreds of millions of decent
hard-working good people are worse than
the Nazis and as for the suggestion that
we should go out and and devastate her
whole cities
as part of the the war on terror that
would be absolutely catastrophic that
would unite frankly not just the Muslim
world but most of the world against us
and it would be the absolutely certain
way of losing this war and of making
sure that in future it would also be
American cities that would be devastated